- Narrator: Every season of
"Game of Thrones" gave us a
new battle or two that
attempted to top the last.
All the blood, gore, and
fireballs you saw on screen
would mean absolutely nothing without
the sound mix behind it.
From weapons, to wights, to music,
a lot goes into what
you hear during a given
"Game of Thrones" action scene.
It's not just about how
they made all the sounds
but how many they need to make.
Warning: Spoilers are coming.
To break down how the sound
in the show's battle scenes
was done, we talked to Tim
Kimmel, the show's Emmy-winning
supervising sound
editor, who's been around
since season three.
- I think one of the hardest
parts of these battle scenes
is when there's so much going
on, trying to find the detail
to not make it just sound
like a wall of sound.
- Narrator: That's no exaggeration.
The Battle of Winterfell
was especially complex.
- I know we maxed out the
amount of tracks we were able to
use on the system we were using,
which I believe is 720 tracks.
And that was just for sound
effects, and sound design,
and Foley, and backgrounds,
so I think on the dialogue side
there was probably another
200 tracks and another
60 tracks or so of music.
- Narrator: This is what
they were dealing with.
It can take weeks to put
this much sound together.
Obviously, there's a lot going on here,
so let's break down some
of these layers one by one.
There are weapons of all shapes and
sizes on "Game of Thrones."
Weapons that catch fire,
kill White Walkers,
and bring dragons out of the sky.
Because the show has been on for so long,
the sound team had a
massive digital library of
prerecorded sounds to pull
from whenever necessary,
but those sounds still had to be made
at one point in time.
Weapon sounds are usually made with Foley,
a process in which real
objects are used to create the
sounds of humans and other
creatures interacting with the
world around them.
So when you're hearing
two swords clashing against
each other, that was likely
the sound of two real
swords banging together.
The sound effects they
use will vary depending
on the character in the fight.
For instance, one factor
that makes Jaime Lannister's
fights different from that
of the other characters:
his fake hand.
Kimmel recalls that the
sounds for Jaime's hand
were actually created using a frying pan.
Listen now, and you
might be able to hear it.
- Euron: Ahhh!
There is also another
incredibly unique use
of Foley during the
Battle of the Bastards.
- There's a moment
where all the arrows are
shot into the air.
You hear nothing but the arrows
traveling through the air,
and instead of a very
typical whooshy sound of the
arrows flying by, we took all
of that out, and all Foley
did was the sound of the quills.
You just hear that flapping
really lightly in the wind
before we then quickly dive
back down into the battle.
- Loose!
- The sounds of death are
such an important thing as
these battles get larger and larger as
the seasons moved along.
- Narrator: A lot of characters
on this show have been
killed in a variety of ways.
Chances are
you won't forget those
final screams and gurgles.
In these instances, top-notch
vocals are essential.
After shooting is done, voice
actors will come into the
studio, partially to
provide all the background
noises you'll hear in
a given battle scene.
These are known in
Hollywood as loop groups.
The voice actors will give
many different options of the
sound of, say, someone getting
stabbed or burned alive.
Depending on the death,
sometimes it's a lower
grunt, and other times
it's a high-pitched screech.
In season eight, episode four,
"The Last of the Starks,"
Rhaegal is brought down
by one of the scorpions.
Before editing and mixing,
the sounds were originally
made by sound designer Paula
Fairfield, who comes up
with most of the dragon
sounds on the show.
Getting the right sound for
this major death involves
some knowledge of anatomy.
- It started out with
a very screechy vocal,
painful vocal, and then
once it hits the throat,
if you listen closely, that vocal turns
into more of just of a gurgle.
You know, like it hit a vocal
chord, and it can't make much
sound, and it's sadly choking on
its own blood at that point.
Once it's about halfway
down towards the water,
you can see the vocals
just kind of disappear.
- Narrator: Emmy-winning
composer Ramin Djawadi's
score has become an iconic
part of "Game of Thrones,"
often providing the
show's emotional backbone.
While Djawadi and Kimmel work separately,
it's part of the sound
team's job to make sure all
elements of the sound work
together with the score.
- You know, that way we can
say, "Oh, look, he's going
really big in this moment.
Let's let music carry this,
and we'll provide some stuff
under it," or, "All right,
he went quiet here.
Let's make sure we have
plenty of detail," or you know,
if he's using, say, higher
strings in that moment,
frequency-wise, we know let's hit
the lower elements harder so
everything can work together.
- Narrator: During some of
the show's standout music
moments, you'll notice that other
sounds are much more toned-down.
A major factor that drives
the sounds they make:
characters, and the ways
they do this are very subtle.
For instance, each army sounds different.
The Lannister army sounds
different from the Stark army,
which will both sound
different from the Dothraki
and the Unsullied.
- Yeah, I mean, each army
had their own sounds, their
own kind of palette that we worked with
to kind of try to set them
apart from each other.
- Narrator: So a Lannister
spear might sound completely
different from a Stark spear,
and overall battles sound
completely different from one another.
The Battle of the Bastards
was a largely horse-driven
battle that then turned into
human-versus-human combat.
Meanwhile, battles like
Hardhome, Beyond the Wall,
and Winterfell were about humans
versus wights and White Walkers.
Once you bring the undead
into a battle, you're dealing
with many more layers of
different vocals and movements,
which often include the
sounds of bones to represent
their often skinless bodies.
When balancing all this
sound, the most important part
is not to lose track of
the moments bringing the
characters and stories forward.
- You know, make it feel like
a big battle, but make sure
you hear that specific sword
of, you know, a main character
who's attacking somebody.
So even though there's 30
people around him fighting,
and you want to feel that,
you gotta make sure you can
hear the detail of, you know,
your specific guy fighting,
and his sword hitting whoever
he's fighting's sword,
and if he stabs them, you know,
making all of this stuff cut through.
- You know nothing, Jon Snow.